bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat au programme de votre
matinée à la suite de l'examen par les
sénateurs de la réforme ferroviaire un
texte qui avait provoqué 14 jours de
grève à la SNCF lors de son examen par
les députés à l'Assemblée nationale hier
à les sénateurs ont réaffirmé leur
intention de maîtriser l'endettement du
système ferroviaire français pour
Jean-Jacques filleul sénateur PS le
poids de la dette accumulée entrave
l'avenir de notre système ferroviaire il
faut dire que la dette s'élève à 44
milliards d'euros alors sans plus tarder
direction l'hémicycles du Sénat pour
suivre cette séance à tout à l'heure
nous savons donc j'ai été saisi d'un
amendement du Gouvernement qui vous a
été distribué mes chers collègues
tout le monde l'a sous les yeux monsieur
capo canelas vous voulez nous dire quel
sort vous réservez à vos amendements
au vu de la maman gouvernementale qui me
satisfait je retire le 85 et 82 donc au
profit de celui que le ministre a bien
voulu présenter merci Monsieur
pour l'amendement numéro 6
vous le maintenez alors je mets au bois
l'amendement
194 du gouvernement
alors je vais demander la vie de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente je rappelle
que la Commission et développement
durable avait souhaité demander la vie
du gouvernement nous avons eu son avis
et en plus le gouvernement a déposé un
abonnement
ce qui a amené notre collègue Vincent
caprocanella ça a retiré les deux
amendements qu'il avait déposé donc je
suis tout à fait habilité au nom de la
commission donner un avis favorable à
l'amendement de Monsieur le Ministre
merci monsieur le rapporteur pas d'autre
demande d'explication de vote donc je
mets aux voix qui est pour l'amendement
194 du gouvernement
qui est contre
l'amendement est adopté et il fait
tomber l'amendement numéro 6
voilà donc je vous informe qu'il y aura
dans peu de coordination avec cet
amendement qui vient d'être voté dans
d'autres articles donc cela sera fait
bien sûr je passe à l'amendement numéro
32 de Monsieur
vous savez la parole chers collègues
on est toujours dans le même esprit tout
arbitrage entre les présidents des deux
entités mobilités et réseaux ne peuvent
être effectués qu'à la faveur du
président du conseil d'administration
dans mon esprit qui devait être réseau
qui est le seul garant du point de vue
de l'indépendance donc de l'utilisation
de ce réseau qui est ouvert à l'ensemble
je le précise des entreprises
ferroviaires
monsieur le rapporteur de la commission
madame la Présidente si nous adoption
l'amendement
32 que Louis viennent de présenter
cela reviendrait à octroyer de fait la
préminence du président du directoire
non plus sur le vice-président mais sur
le président délégué ce qui n'est pas
l'objectif poursuivi puisqu'il est dit
dans le texte que par ailleurs les
décisions sont prises à l'unanimité et
qu'en cas des accords c'est le président
du conseil de surveillance qui tranche
avis défavorable monsieur le ministre
je vais donc mettre au bois cet
amendement numéro 32 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission à la vie
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient cet
amendement n'est pas adopté je vais
mettre au revoir
l'article premier de ce projet de loi
pas de demande d'intervention qui est
pour
qui est contre
l'article premier est adopté
après l'article premier je suis saisi
d'un amendement numéro 114 de Monsieur
Marigny monsieur le Président vous avez
la parole merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je sollicite quelques instants votre
attention pour faire un peu d'histoire
car c'est en 1897 que les surtaxes
locales temporaires ont été créés pour
la première fois
il s'agit d'une majoration minime du
prix du billet de train en vue de
financer des investissements dans une
gare déterminée
majoration a quitté par les seuls
usagers au départ ou à destination de la
gare en question
ce régime juridique a fait l'objet de
différentes modifications
au cours du temps
il a été réécrit par un acte dit loi de
puis revu en 1977 revue en 1993
les surtaxes locales temporaires étaient
alors exclusivement affecté au
remboursement des annuités d'un emprunt
susceptible d'être contracté par une
collectivité territoriale une ville par
exemple en vue de réaliser des
investissements
utiles aux voyageurs de la gare et c'est
pourquoi la surtaxe est dite temporaire
elle est temporaire parce qu'elle ne
s'applique que pendant la période
d'amortissement de l'emprunt
je prends un exemple volontairement loin
de mon département sur le ministre une
surtaxe locale temporaire a été ainsi
instituée pour la gare de Biarritz en
2009 et jusqu'en 2022
ce régime juridique
bien que très éprouvé
est devenu désuet car il n'est
probablement pas en phase avec le droit
communautaire il ne prend pas en compte
l'ouverture à la concurrence du
transport ferroviaire de voyageurs et en
conséquence le transfert de la gestion
de la grande majorité des gares à une
branche autonome de la SNCF doit être
prise en considération
le régime des surtaxes temporaires ne
tient pas compte de la multiplication
des autorités organisatrices de
transport qui utilise une même gare
comme on le sait bien ici puisque mes
chers collègues vous êtes tous des
spécialistes de ce sujet peut s'agir de
la SNCF des régions de l'État donc la
mandement que je vous soumets vise
actualiser le régime des surtaxes
locales temporaires afin que les
gestionnaires de gare et les
collectivités territoriales concernées
puisse à nouveau utiliser ce mode de
financement je suggère de renommer ce
dispositif contribution local temporaire
elle serait toujours exclusivement
affectée à des investissements elle ne
servirait plus directement au
remboursement des intérêts d'emprunt
mais s'inscrirait dans un plan de
financement global des investissements
et au moment où
l'enjeu des quartiers de gare est un
enjeu d'aménagement qui se renforce dans
beaucoup de régions et dans beaucoup
d'agglomérations il me semble qu'il faut
y intégrer par exemple s'agissant des
installations ferroviaires la mise aux
normes handicap les salles d'attentes la
sonorisation et différents aménagements
extérieurs une partie de ces travaux
pourrait ainsi être financé contribuant
à inscrire la garde dans un pôle des
changes multimodal la contribution
serait perçue selon des termes fixés par
convention au des différents financeurs
la décision d'instituer une telle
contribution serait soumise à la
probation des différents partenaires
c'est-à-dire des autorités
organisatrices de transport j'achève en
indiquant que bien sûr il faut veiller à
limiter l'impact financier sur l'usager
et c'est pourquoi je propose que la
contribution ne puisse être supérieure à
4% du prix du billet ou en valeur
absolue à 2 euros je reprends mon
exemple de la gare de Biarritz la slt la
surtax local temporaire actuellement en
vigueur et de 2% du prix du billet ou au
maximum en valeur absolue 1,3 euros
ce serait le gestionnaire de la gare qui
serait l'agent collecteur
contribution locale temporaire serait
soumise à la TVA et j'insiste sur le
fait que monsieur le ministre que ce
dispositif résulte d'un travail
approfondie réalisée depuis déjà un
certain temps plus d'une année avec la
SNCF qui me semble
pouvoir utiliser à bon escient un tel
mécanisme merci de votre attention merci
Monsieur le Sénator avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
notre collègue film Marini nous propose
d'instituer une contribution locale
temporaire pour financer en tout ou en
partie des dépenses d'investissement il
a présenté des arguments forts pour
justifier la présentation de son
amendement je dois indiquer que la
commission Développement Durable
infrastructure équipement et aménagement
du territoire avait émis un avis
défavorable à cet amendement en estimant
que
il aurait pour conséquence d'augmenter
le prix des billets pour les usagers
alors j'ai eu l'occasion d'en parler il
y a quelques instants avec Monsieur le
Ministre et je pense qu'il serait
intéressant que nous puissions avoir
l'avis du Gouvernement sur la question
de manière à ce que la Commission puisse
éventuellement je ne dis pas qu'elle le
fera éventuellement revoir sa position
si l'argumentation présentait tant par
l'auteur de l'amendement que par le
ministre nous paraissait je dirais
parfaitement justifié
merci monsieur le rapporteur alors
l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci madame la Présidente ce
président Marini l'amendement que vous
souhaitez l'approbation de la Haute
Assemblée est un amendement
qui est partiellement
réglé par les dispositions existantes
par décret pour ce qui est de
l'intérieur des gars et vous soulignez
combien et c'est une réalité nous en
avions eu discussion hier l'enjeu des
gares est aussi un enjeu d'un termealité
et que de plus en plus les collectivités
les différentes collectivités les
autorités organisatrices de transport
ont à se saisir c'est d'ailleurs une un
problème de compétences dans les lois de
réforme territoriales ou chacun essaie
de regarder comment quelle est la
collectivité qui est en quelque sorte
chef de file sur cette question
avec une réalité c'est que notamment
dans des villes qui sont Devil moyenne
vous avez parlé de Biarritz vous auriez
pu parler de 50 ans
plus proche de chez vous mais un certain
nombre de gares posent des difficultés
de différents ordres d'abord
d'aménagement en lien direct avec la
gare ce qui est importante il faut qu'il
y ait un lien direct les aménagements
immédiats environnement de gaz je pense
notamment aux questions de stationnement
pour lesquelles des délégations de
services publics ou des concessions de
stationnement ne sont pas la réponse
pertinente dans la mesure il n'y a pas
suffisamment de rentabilité économique
et donc c'est la collectivité locale
souvent la mairie qui est confronté à
cette difficulté liée à cette forme de
centralité ferroviaire
il y a aussi d'autres situations pour
lesquelles votre amendement peut
apporter
des réponses en tout cas une réflexion
qu'elle convient de poursuivre je pense
aux gars patrimoniales
un certain nombre de gares de début du
siècle dernier sont de véritables
monuments elles sont fermées elles
posent des problèmes de sécurité alors
qu'elles sont extrêmement valorisantes
pour le territoire et que l'équilibre
économique est impossible à trouver en
l'état y compris lors de changement
d'affectation d'usage avec centre
d'affaires si tenter qu'on puisse les
appeler ainsi mais qu'il y a bon nombre
de collectivités confrontés à une
difficulté de trouver une utilisation
complémentaire à la gare pour obtenir un
équilibre économique
ainsi à la fois pour ces questions
stationnement pense qu'il faut que le
stationnement lié véhicule
d'automobilier à l'usage du train
puisse amener des investissements qui
soient supportés par les usagers du
train et non par le contribuable de
l'ensemble des collectivités c'est dans
les abords des gars et donc cette
situation et je parle avec
la complément technique de
représentant de la DGITM aujourd'hui les
dispositions réglementaires ne
permettent pas par ce biais de cette
surtax local temporaire de répondre à la
question s'agit pas d'une taxe nouvelle
vous l'avez indiqué elle est fort
ancienne
elle mérite d'être peut-être réactualisé
non pas et là je m'éloigne de votre
motivation il s'agit en rien d'un
contexte de mise en concurrence ou
d'ouverture à la concurrence je pense
que c'est sans lien
mais c'est bien la nécessité de trouver
des moyens
d'améliorer de financer de retrouver
attractivité des pôles ferroviaires
urbains en répondant précisément des
préoccupations sont celles des élus
locaux
alors vous évoquez le précédent de
Biarritz
vous évoquez également des pourcentages
élevés 4%, peut-être élevé 2%
peut-être un pourcentage plus acceptable
je pense que votre amendement est un
amendement d'appel sur lequel nous
pouvons en tout cas c'est la suggestion
du gouvernement
continuer à travailler pour en avoir une
formulation la plus précise notamment
sur les contours des travaux
éligibles en quelque sorte à ce
dispositif qu'il ne soit pas sans lien
et donc il faut bien un caractère de
causalité ou un lien direct entre les
travaux et l'aspect ferroviaire de la
taxe et par ailleurs que ce cela soit
suffisamment contraint pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de charges excessives
qui serait supporté par les usagers même
si
un euro payé par usager pour trouver un
stationnement adapté qui lui-même ne
serait pas nécessairement payant cette
quelque chose qui peut s'entendre et
certainement faciliter l'ingénierie
financière très compliquée voilà donc
cette
position de bon sens pour essayer de
résoudre un certain nombre de
difficultés rencontrées se posent moins
dans des centres grands centres urbains
ou des métropoles parce que
notamment les stationnements le rapport
au stationnement public et différent de
la part des usagers des habitants mais
aussi et je vois cette aspect je suis
très sensible de pouvoir trouver des
solutions assez garres qui sont de
véritables joyeux du patrimoine
architectural ferroviaire valorisant
pour des villes et les villes se
trouvent confrontées souvent avec les
territoires à des difficultés pour
trouver des modes de financement dans le
temps progressivement pour redonner vie
en tout cas images à ce qui est un
aspect patrimonial évident
je pense donc que nous pourrions et je
m'en remets la sagesse de la Haute
Assemblée mais nous pourrions de façon
conservatoire adoptée quitte à
poursuivre les travaux de sorte que lors
de la CMP nous puissions avoir un
dispositif pleinement partagé et surtout
opératoire
merci monsieur le ministre c'est une
demande de parole pour explication de
vente de Monsieur
monsieur le ministre il s'agit pas
d'ouverture à la concurrence vous l'avez
dit donc pas de problème de ce côté-là
c'est amendement est très intéressant
d'abord la première chose qui me fait
réagir positivement c'est qu'il s'agit
pas de la création d'une taxe chers
collègues cette taxe existe elle existe
donc il y a pas la création d'une
nouvelle taxe sur lequel nous serions
plus réticents si c'était le cas mais
ici dans ce domaine nous avons une taxe
qui existe elle a été utilisée pour
améliorer et moderniser la garde
Cagnes-sur-Mer donc je suis le maire
voilà voilà et donc et donc j'ai touché
du doigt
j'ai touché du doigt l'intérêt d'avoir
cette contribution là et je me suis
aperçu que grâce à ça nous avions pu
améliorer encore une fois pour les
usagers en priorité cet aspect là donc
l'extension au pôle d'intermodalité qui
touche la garde avec l'idée que vous
venez de soulever monsieur le ministre
d'améliorer par exemple le parc relais
nécessaire qu'il faut pour faire
fonctionner les gares me paraît aller
tout à fait dans le bon sens et si vous
rajoutez monsieur le ministre qui en
plus il faut sauver le patrimoine de la
nation où nous avons par exemple dans
les Alpes-Maritimes attendent une gare
qui ressemble presque à la gare de Lyon
qui a été faite par Mussolini d'ailleurs
à l'époque et qui est fermée aujourd'hui
et qui est effectivement mauvais état et
bien je souhaite je souhaite que ces
ensembles immobiliers remarquables
c'est comme ça la vie bon ces ensembles
immobiliers remarquables puissent être
sauvés
merci monsieur le sénateur monsieur le
rapporteur de la commission du
développement durable merci madame la
Présidente
la commission n'avait pas forcément
pris en compte lors de l'examen
finalement du texte les aspects qui ont
été évoqués par l'auteur de l'amendement
par le ministre et par lui-même
c'est-à-dire l'aspect patrimonial et
aussi l'aspect lié à l'intermodalité et
donc nous avons le président de la
Commission à moi-même consulté
rapidement les membres de la commission
présents dans l'hémicycle et nous ne
sommes pas opposés à l'adoption en
définitive cet amendement mais nous
voulons l'encadrer davantage et en
particulier il me semble nécessaire
qu'en page 2 de l'amendement à l'article
L 21 23 3-4 nous indiquions que le taux
ne peut être supérieur à 2% et pas à 4%
comme il est indiqué dans l'amendement
présenté par Philippe Marini voilà donc
la vie de la commission du développement
durable
monsieur Marini votre point de vue allez
alors madame la Présidente d'abord je
voudrais remercier très chaleureusement
monsieur le ministre de l'analyse très
approfondie et très positive à laquelle
il a bien voulu se livrer en effet il y
a beaucoup d'enjeux auxquels cette
ressource peut contribuer dans un
montage ceci a bien été dit mais on sait
bien que les quartiers de gare les
aménagements intérieurs et surtout
extérieurs sont des enjeux
urbains considérables et que de telles
opérations mettent forcément en présence
différentes parties prenantes et à cet
égard moi je demeure quand même à ces
attachés pardonnez-moi d'ouvrir et de
refermer la parenthèse au financement
croisé n'est-ce pas la possibilité de
faire venir l'argent de partout on peut
se le procurer et un élément comme la
contribution locale peut tout à fait
utilement
à la mise au point d'un montage complexe
alors je suis tout à fait prêt monsieur
le rapporteur a accepté une
rectification
du plafond effectivement
par rapport à la valeur totale des
billets achetés bon j'aurais tendance à
dire un peu pour principe que je
proposais 4 % vous me dites 2 moi je
verrai mieux la barre à 3% sachant que
ça va encore aller à l'Assemblée
nationale qu'il y aura encore quelques
précisions à apporter mais à cet égard
monsieur le ministre je m'en remets tout
à fait
je m'en remets tout à fait à ceux qui
vous semblera justifier me semble que 2%
c'est tiré un peu bas 4% bon j'ai
peut-être tiré un peu long voilà on fait
en tout état de cause merci à la
commission d'avoir bien voulu réexaminer
le sujet à la suite des explications qui
ont été données en particulier
par le gouvernement merci monsieur le
Président pour une explication de vote
madame cherche
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre donc j'ai bien suivi le débat
c'est une
nous regardons avec bienveillance cette
cette affaire et cette taxe en effet qui
peut être très utile et en tout cas elle
paraît très dynamique puisqu'elle va
directement ce pourquoi elle est faite
et ça c'est quand même une bonne une
bonne démarche nous ne nous obtiendrons
sur ce vote bien sûr parce que nous
considérons pour notre part qu'encore
une fois on va taxer un peu plus les
usagers vous comprenez que nous sommes
sur la question de la protection du
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens et
nous ne pouvons pas dire qui on va faire
dans la loi on va installer une nouvelle
taxe considérant que normalement le
tarif du billet devrait suffire pour
faire ses travaux et puisqu'il n'y
suffisent pas il faut donc surtaxer
voilà donc nous avons une écoute
bienveillante parce que nous considérons
en effet que c'est tout à fait dynamique
fléchés et encadré
mais au regard du pouvoir d'achat des
Français qui est quand même dans un état
catastrophique nous ne pourrons pas
voter donc nous obtiendrons sur cet
amendement
merci monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente pas à ce
stade tranché
le montant je pense que un vrai débat
parlementaire mais vous même monsieur le
Président avait indiqué que le parcours
de cet amendement si le texte est voté
c'est important parce que s'il n'était
pas voté et votre amendement auquel vous
tenez particulièrement tomberait il
serait malheureux on est bien et donc
essayer de convaincre monsieur de
bien fonder comme l'a fait monsieur
caoutchouc à l'instant sur une autre
question
pour être précis vous merci pour cette
position qui est position non pas
d'ouverture de compréhension du
dispositif
il est important de souligner et
finalement je fais
une forme de travail d'explication
parlementaire en lieu et place de
l'auteur de l'amendement mais ce qui ne
serait pas payé par l'usager serait payé
par le contribuable
or ça n'est pas précisément le
contribuable qui doit être
là qui doit supporter cet axe qui est
minime et qui par rapport aux précédents
de Biarritz que je connais peu mais
s'inscrit dans le temps et donc avec
suffisamment de
longueur de temps permettant d'étaler
des investissements il est important
d'encadrer
parce qu'il ne faudrait pas que cette
contribution soit perçue comme une
modalité de financement absolue et au
grand droit toute forme d'investissement
qui en effet pourrait avoir des
conséquences
fâcheuses mais pour autant elle peut
être une réponse adaptée à un certain
nombre de situations qui ne trouvent pas
solution
compte tenu l'absence d'un financement
global et de ce point de vue il est
important que l'usager puisse être
puisqu'il doit être prioritairement
destinataire des infrastructures c'est
peut-être aussi une des limites
supplémentaires à mettre que l'usager
puisse contribuer plutôt que le
contribuable sous prétexte qu'il habite
une ville où il y a un pôle le
ferroviaire important
merci monsieur le ministre je vais donc
mettre au voie
cet amendement numéro 114 rectifié
en page 2 ou le taux de la contribution
locale temporaire ne peut être
supérieure à
2%. donc qui est favorable à cet
amendement un sir rectifié
qui est
contre cet amendement qui s'abstient cet
amendement est donc adopté ainsi
rectifié
l'amendement numéro 162 rectifié tombe
je fais donc je mets au voie donc
l'article 1er bis qui est pour
l'article premier bisque qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient cet amendement cet
article pardon est adopté article
premier terre même vote premier cataire
quater pardon même vote nous arrivons à
l'article 2 avec un amendement numéro 50
et je donne la parole à ma dame Cohen
merci madame la Présidente comme nous
l'avons annoncé dans notre intervention
générale la structuration en trois
épiques ne nous convainc pas tant en
termes d'efficacité que de pérennité
d'une part en termes d'efficacité ce
n'est pas être nostalgique du passé ou
même être rétrograde nous pensons qu'il
faut un service public ferroviaire
unifié intégrant réellement
infrastructures et exploitation
rappelons qu'en 1997 nous avions été les
seuls à pointer du doigt les risques que
feraient porter une séparation sur le
système ferroviaire nous n'avions
malheureusement pas tort et il aura
fallu 15 ans pour s'en rendre compte les
directives européennes actuelles
n'empêchent pas une telle réunification
avec une externalisation des deux
fonctions essentielles et les directives
futures ne sont pas encore écrites nous
pensons que la France grande nation
ferroviaire avec d'autres États
européens peut faire la différence et
imposer son modèle ferroviaire de plus
la l'entremise en cause la notion
d'épique par la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne ne semble pas vous
poser le moindre problème ce qui je
l'avoue ne nous rassure guerre en effet
au vu des schémas proposés ce sera sans
doute encore une fois à cause de
l'Europe telle qu'elle est construite
aujourd'hui si demain SNCF mobilité
devait être privatisés vous nous dites
qu'il n'en est rien mais tout dans ce
texte va dans ce sens du rattachement de
la DCF à SNCF réseau en passant par le
transfert de bien de SNCF mobilité vers
SNCF réseau ainsi il ne restera à SNCF
mobilité que ces missions de
transporteur qui sont ouvertes à la
concurrence aujourd'hui pour le fret et
au vu de l'exposé des mot du projet de
loi demain pour le transport de
voyageurs ce que vous réunifiez ce n'est
pas le système mais la gestion de
l'infrastructure en fragilisant
l'entreprise publique SNCF ce que vous
mettez en place est un glissement du
service public ferroviaire vers un
service public centré sur la seule
gestion de l'infrastructure les
interactions extrêmement fortes entre
infrastructures et mobilité sur les
plantes techniques sur les plans
également de la sécurité de l'efficacité
conduisent à appréhender le chemin de
fer comme un système intégré pour
rechercher en permanence un optimum
global c'est pourquoi nous proposons la
suppression de l'article 2 de ce projet
de loi je vous remercie merci madame la
sénatrice la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
la Commission a considérer qu'il était
impossible de donner un avis favorable à
cet amendement qui est cohérent avec la
proposition
de leurs auteurs de ne créer qu'un seul
épique dans un souci d'intégration du
système ferroviaire public
ceci étant tout le monde sait bien que
nous n'arriverons pas à obtenir de la
Commission européenne qu'il y ait un
seul épique nous avons déjà grâce à
l'action de Fédéric obtenu que la
Commission et en particulier le
commissaire Calas accepte un système
verticalement intégré
si effectivement nous votion votre
amendement le risque serait considérable
que la cour de schisme l'Union
européenne Vienne sanctionner
effectivement cette partie du texte donc
la commission a émis un avis défavorable
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
soit nécessaire de revenir sur toutes
les éléments explicatifs je pense dans
mon propos de discussion générale avoir
précisé combien nous avions fait de
grands progrès il faut dire la position
de la France n'était pas défendue donc
nous ne pouvions pas être entendus au
niveau de la Commission européenne il
n'y avait aucune exigence je dirais même
qu'il y avait un accompagnement avec une
certaine vision d'un libéralisme
sans limite et surtout sans forme de
protection de ce qui est pour nous
fondamental c'est-à-dire les obligations
de service public la mise en concurrence
n'est pas une difficulté si tenter
qu'elle ne se fasse pas au détriment des
règles du service public que le service
public et les opérateurs publics ne
soient pas dans une situation
discriminante et le
système que vous proposez me paraît être
heureux incompatible nous avons réussi à
obtenir avec une une action coordonnée
je citais l'action menée par mon
collègue mon homologue allemand et
laquelle bien sûr nous avons participé
nous étions même à l'initiative pour
faire entendre cette réalité simple à la
commission nous pouvons avoir un mode de
gouvernance qui réponde aux enjeux
nationaux une forme de principe de
subsidiarité pour ce qui est de
l'organisation ce pourquoi avec fierté
je vous présente un groupe public qui
est unifiée qui marque
la constitution d'un groupe d'un
établissement public permettant de
rassembler les métiers et d'avoir une
garantie sur statutaire le tout dans le
respect des fonctions essentielles et du
régulateur
et à chaque fois je me tourne vers
monsieur apocanellas vous pourriez
embriguer la présidence peut-être un
jour enfin je veux pas donner d'idée
mais donc aujourd'hui vous êtes
par rapport à une proposition qui est
logique
lorsque l'on se place sur votre
la philosophie qui la vôtre mais qui
n'est pas réaliste juridiquement
acceptable dans le cadre des règles
existantes au niveau européen et donc la
vie sera défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre pour une
explication de vote émotionnel
on voit bien que là il y a des
philosophies totalement différentes et
on mérite de la cohérence de votre ligne
depuis le départ j'avoue que je suis
totalement opposé à cette vision non pas
de la SNCF de papa mais de grandes-papa
bon et donc quand on est là quand on est
là
vous m'avez entendu hier bon je ne suis
pas très favorable à trois épiques etc
mais franchement
ce qui nous attendent demeure c'est une
ouverture à la concurrence elle arrive
elle arrive vous l'avez déjà d'ailleurs
en partie alors préparez-vous
préparez-vous plutôt que d'être derrière
votre ligne Maginot en attendant que le
ciel nous tombe sur la tête essayons
pour une fois d'être offensif essayons
pour une fois de nous préparer
efficacement parce que le monde n'attend
pas parce que le monde bouge et c'est
pas l'immobilisme qui nous fera gagner
les guerres
merci monsieur le sénateur madame Cohen
pour une explication de vote
oui les arguments que je viens
d'entendre ne sont pas des arguments en
fait c'est en asseine des principes et
un dogme effectivement c'est un service
aujourd'hui qui est ouvert à la
concurrence grâce à vous et à votre
sensibilité politique mais nous ne
pouvons pas soutenir cette position pour
nous le transport c'est un service
public c'est un bien rendu un bien
commun et nous et nous pensons que ça
n'est pas être un gars et être dépassé
que de continuer à défendre et d'y voir
au contraire des atouts alors nous
apprécions et j'apprécie effectivement
la bataille qui commence à être menée
notamment par le ministre des Transports
mais on en est loin enfin on en est
qu'au début je dirais et que pour
l'instant on reste dans le symbolique et
par rapport à ce qu'a dit le binistre le
fait de soutenir et de voter notre
amendement l'aurait certainement rendu
plus fort au niveau européen dans les
négociations à continuer à poursuivre
donc nous pensons que c'est une erreur
politique que de ne pas voter notre
amendement et nous continuons à
persister sur cette sur cette ligne qui
nous semble une ligne d'avenir merci
madame la sénatrice je vais mettre aux
voix cet amendement numéro 50 qui a
recueilli deux avis défavorables l'un de
la commission l'un du gouvernement qui
est pour
qui est contre cet amendement n'est pas
adopté amendement numéro 33 monsieur
vous avez la parole
je vais peut-être faire plaisir à Madame
Cohen bon donc
bien il s'agit de maintenir la
dénomination de RFF pour le gestionnaire
d'infrastructures la disparition du
sigle est très négatif parce qu'elle est
mal vécue et les vécu même comme des
aveux par les personnels et c'est le
retour à une SNCF toute puissante donc
les syndicats les syndicats les
syndicats font état de malaise social
interne à RFF et du fait de l'effet
rouleau compresseur que la SNCF exerce
monsieur le Sénator a vide la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
alors je voudrais moi comme la
felouinaigre rendre hommage à
l'excellent travail qui a été effectué
par les personnels de réseau ferrés de
France et
bien évidemment
personne n'a contesté leur travail et
donc il est bien qu'on puisse ici le
rendre hommage comme il faut rendre
hommage à l'ensemble des activités qui
ont été menées depuis de nombreuses
décennies par les personnels de la SNCF
l'organisation ferroviaire française est
quand même une organisation exemplaire
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'il ne faut
pas apporter quelques modifications et
nous sommes d'ailleurs au coeur de ce
débat pour apporter les bonnes
modifications monsieur luinet je dis
bien les bonnes modifications
alors dans ces conditions puisque nous
avons décidé de mettre en place un gros
public industriel
unifié il est logique que les trois
épiques soient dénommés SNCF pour les
pics de tête SNCF mobilité pour
l'exploiter en ferroviaire et SNCF
réseau pour le gestionnaire
d'infrastructures je crois que cela
donne une image forte de ce groupe
public et donc la commission a émis un
avis défavorable à l'amendement de
Monsieur qu'il a me semble-t-il affaibli
beaucoup avec cet amendement qui
affaiblirait beaucoup le futur groupe
public
Simpson ravi du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur lorsque vous parlez des
syndicats comme ça sonne faux
permettez-moi de vous dire que
vous parliez d'une vision pas séiste je
pense que c'est en effet bien ce que
vous plaidez par votre amendement
d'abord parce que vous ne pouvez pas
vous faire le porte-parole de l'ensemble
des personnels monsieur le rapportera
raison comment seriez-vous cette fois je
précise bien le défenseur des salariés
des FF considérant que vous auriez été
désigné pour porter un malaise ou un
mal-être social et nous n'avons pas
rencontré les mêmes
certainement parce que l'une des
difficultés de cette établissement à
1500 personnes 1500 voilà la loi de 97
que vous avez voté que vous avez soutenu
c'est de faire dans l'artificiel de
faire dans la séparatisme tout en
ligotant les fonctions parce que vous
savez que d'un côté vous allez la DCF
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela je vous allez
rappeler à membre prédécesseur monsieur
busco que la France est condamnée devant
la SSJ CEE et que c'est le fait de ne
pas assurer les fonctions essentielles
les la séparation qui permettent de
donner de la clarté dans ce qui relève
de l'infrastructure et ceux qui le
relève du transport donc nous allons
grâce à notre texte éviter que la France
soit condamnée par les malfaçons
législatives de votre majorité
précédente et nous allons éviter qu'il y
ait l'explosion des métiers d'un côté la
DCF de l'autre côté SNCF Infra puis RF
1500 personnes le mal-être il est là sur
un groupe de 150 000 personnes d'avoir
isolé 5500 personnes en les privant en
plus de toute capacité réelle
d'impulsion d'initiative de travail en
commun de mutualisation des moyens ah
oui ça a permis quand même de dépenser
beaucoup d'argent en communication
et RF fait de très belles publicités
elles sont superbes et Jean félicite le
cabinet de communication je le vois pas
beaucoup l'intérêt pour RFF d'avoir de
belles campagnes de publicité de
publicité de communication à la télé
dans les journaux
alors même que ils sont gestionnaires de
d'infrastructures ou devrait l'être et
qui
n'auront aucune retombée commerciale
donc
aujourd'hui ce que me disent les
personnes des FF que je rencontre et
avec lesquels j'avais discussion pour
expliciter la réforme ça veut dire mais
je m'adressais à elle en ayant la
famille cheminotte ça représente quelque
chose la famille cheminotes en terme
d'histoire en termes de patrimoine
commun de volonté et eux-mêmes me disait
mais monsieur le ministre vous vous
trompez
nous ne sommes pas considérés comme
faisant partie de famille cheminotes
j'ai été très marquée par ce témoignage
c'était une jeune femme ingénieur des FF
mais disons nous ne savons pas si
finalement nous appartenons à la famille
cheminotes et bien nous allons clarifier
les choses vous restez dans le passé
nous nous souhaitons une structure qui
soit une structure qui donne de
l'impulsion qui donne de la force qui
donne de la modernité à une vision
stratégique du ferroviaire en France
une explication de votre madame Sosh
madame la Présidente Monsieur mini j'ai
bien entendu monsieur negre défendent
cet amendement il défend un modèle
complètement dépassé qui a prouvé en
plus ça complète inéfique
inefficacité depuis 15 ans qui a
contribué à mettre cette grande
entreprise de ferroviaire dans un état
relativement catastrophique donc je
comprends pas cette attachement un
modèle qui justement prouvé qu'il était
inefficace ensuite nous nous sommes
effectivement aussi pour la symbolique
alors autant nous aurions aimé que tout
un épi qui s'appelle SNCF mais qu'il y
ait ses épis qui s'appelle d'un côté
SNCF mobilité SNCF réseau ne nous disent
qu'on vient pas vous vous voyez bien
puisque en effet nous souhaitons au
maximum de ce que nous pourrons faire au
cours de nos amendements faire un modèle
intégré et en tout cas faire en sorte
que cette famille se cheminote se
retrouve et en effet nous n'avons pas dû
rencontrer les mêmes personnels
de RFF qui ne savent plus très bien où
ils sont depuis 15 ans et donc je pense
que c'est au contraire pour une grande
chance aujourd'hui que de pouvoir se
être réintégré dans cette grande famille
cheminotes à laquelle ils appartiennent
et pour cela le projet de loi donne des
signaux intéressants en se réappropriant
ce terme SNCF qui est notre bien commun
donc nous votre rencontre votre
amendement bien merci madame la
sénatrice nationale pour une explication
de vote
et bien je remercie tout de suite le
rapporteur qui dans sa grande sagesse
rendue lui un hommage au personnel de
RFF qui sont peut-être pas alors dans la
grande famille intégrée ils ont
peut-être été mis sur la touche c'est
pas de l'Orphée ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième la deuxième c'est que
cet amendement je ne pensais pas qu'il
suscite autant de réactions
importantes sur la gauche parce que
franchement ça revenait à dire RFF a
fait son travail
c'était pas une grande structure
justement justement alors qu'elle était
toute petite elle a réussi à faire un
travail qui a été reconnu et à partir de
là je m'étonne de la réaction
extrêmement forte développée qu'il y a
par rapport à cet amendement du coup du
coup j'en déduis que j'avais touché
juste
sénateur la parole est à Monsieur
filleul
oui je vais passer quelques secondes
simplement pour dire à Louis que
simplement pour dire à lui quand même tu
nous as parlé longuement d'avenir avec
force et tu restes pacéiste sur 1997 je
comprends pas je comprends pas parce que
nous sommes quand même devant un texte
qui va permettre à la SNCF d'être
rassemblés verticalement intégré avec un
réseau une SSR réseau qui va jouer son
rôle qu'il a joué en tant que RFM mais
on le sait bien avec beaucoup de
difficultés et ça a coûté très cher en
même temps SNCF réseau c'est 1800
salariés qui viennent de RFF 45 000 qui
vont venir de SNCF Infra et 13650 pour
être précis salarié qui viennent de la
DCF c'est une grosse maison qui va jouer
un rôle majeur et je pense
qu'effectivement il fallait dans cette
proposition de loi qu'on puisse changer
le nom des FF en fait ça n'a pas
beaucoup d'importance ce qui est
important c'est l'avenir et c'est pas de
rester à 1997 merci Monsieur le Sénator
je vais mettre haut voir cet amendement
numéro 33 qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables de la commission l'un du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre cet amendement n'est pas
adopté deux amendements en discussion
communes l'amendement numéro 86 monsieur
capo canelas pour le présenter merci
madame la Présidente je vais vous
présenter donc l'amendement 86 monsieur
le ministre a bien voulu dire il y a
quelques minutes que j'avais la passion
pour une régulation stricte alors j'ai
une deuxième passion pour les gares
voilà si j'ai une passion pour une
régulation stricte et sans doute parce
que j'aime bien les Comé de marché mais
réguler encadré voilà on a quelques
échanges sur ce genre de sujet donc j'y
contribue alors la passion pour les
gares j'y viens simplement
sans espérer un jour Monsieur ministre
pour reprendre ce collier tout à l'heure
sans espérer un jour être patron des
gars ni Diony du régulateur ni du gars
sur mes électeurs mais je viens en gare
par le réseau
parce que je pense que les gares et le
réseau ont beaucoup à voir alors cet
article 2 met effectivement en place le
gestionnaire d'infrastructures unifiée
c'était l'article important SNCF réseau
il détermine les modalités de
fonctionnement de SNCF réseau et pose
donc le principe du partage de la
gestion de l'infrastructure entre le
gestionnaire du réseau et principal
gestionnaire délégué cet amendement
concerne l'émission qui sont confiées à
la SNCF réseau et propose d'étendre le
périmètre
à la pleine propriété et à la gestion
complète des guerres de voyageurs
c'est-à-dire de reprendre dans SNCF
réseau l'ensemble des activités de la
branche gare et connexion alors bien
entendu les arguments qui ont été
échangés sur ce sujet lors des auditions
qui ont eu lieu notamment en commission
et j'ai bien entendu qu'effectivement
déjà le transfert des 45000 agents
étaient un sujet majeur pour ce qui est
aujourd'hui RFF
néanmoins il me semble que le sujet des
gares mérite qu'on s'y arrête un petit
peu et comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
souligner en discussion générale
la gestion des gares est un élément
qu'il faut sans doute améliorer dans le
texte actuel confier à SNCF mobilité la
gestion des gardes ne me paraît pas la
meilleure façon de préparer les
conclusions du quatrième paquet
ferroviaire
par ailleurs il me semble que ce sont
des métiers différents alors on peut
toujours discuter dire après tout
l'Infra et les gars c'est différent on
peut dire que SNCF mobilité à une
tradition commerciale qu'il faut la
retrouver un peu dans les gares
néanmoins en termes d'indépendance même
si ça n'est pas tout à fait même métier
nous sont plus rassurant en termes
d'indépendance de confier à SNCF réseau
la gestion des guerres en effet les
opérateurs futurs lorsqu'il y aura une
ouverture à la concurrence auront comme
question principale la question l'accès
au gars comment on fait par rapport à
tout ça et quelle place leur aurait
donné dans les gares place parce que ça
sera le remplacement commercial il ne
semble pas concevable que SNCF réseau
puisse exercer de façon autonome et non
discriminatoire ses compétences de
gestionnaire du réseau sans pouvoir
gérer directement l'affectation des
voies en gare aux entreprises
ferroviaires utilisatrices et plus
largement l'ensemble des équipements et
bâtiments voyageurs du réseau
ferroviaire voilà Monsieur mise j'espère
vous avoir convaincu tout à l'heure vous
me voyez presque à la tête du régulateur
je pense pas qu'avec ce que je viens de
vous dire vous me voyez elle était
dégâts donc ça me rassurera quelque part
mais j'espère qu'on pourra en tout cas
discuter de ce sujet là
pour l'amendement cette rectifié
monsieur NAIGRE
il s'agit à la Linéa neuf après le mot
gestion d'insérer le mot des gares
pourquoi mais tout simplement et là nous
sommes sur la même démarche avec mon
collègue apocanella il est pas
imaginable pour nous que les gares
soient rattachés à mobilité alors qui
n'est qu'une entreprise ferroviaire
parmi d'autres avec cette ouverture à la
concurrence qui va arriver il est normal
que les gares servent
ah c'est pas une obsession monsieur le
ministre vous allez voir ça arrive c'est
déjà arrivé vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous même que c'est déjà en
cours donc préparez-vous préparez-vous
et préparez surtout la France à cette
ouverture là et je rappelle monsieur le
ministre mais vous le savez fort bien je
rappelle aussi à mes collègues là-bas
qui écoute pas bien là et ils ont raison
de pas bien écouter parce que
l'ouverture à la concurrence en
Allemagne qui est un pays voisin de même
niveau de vie que nous permet de faire
des économies de 20 à 30% sur le prix de
production du kilomètre SNCF ce qui
permet d'avoir un service supplémentaire
meilleur ce qui permet de moins dépenser
d'argent public et donc de moins faire
payer le contribuable donc une ouverture
à la concurrence maîtrisée j'entends
bien maîtriser et quelque chose de
salutaire à la fois pour l'ensemble du
pays à la fois pour les données des
contribuables et surtout pour les
usagers
dont bien entendu ici personne ne parle
on part de la réforme ferroviaire on
parle des épiques on parle de tout sauf
du principal c'est à dire des usagers et
j'aimerais un instant qu'on s'y arrête
que effectivement les usagers soient au
centre de notre démarche plutôt que ça
soit le Comité central bon j'aime le
Comité central mais c'est pas le
principal
en l'occurrence en l'occurrence
en l'occurrence ma démarche est de
pouvoir mettre les gares d'un SNCF
réseau parce que
SNCF réseau ne disposant pas des gares
ça n'a pas de consistance c'est quelque
chose dit logique c'est quelque chose
d'anormal d'ailleurs c'est tellement
illogique anormal que l'Autorité de la
concurrence elle-même et c'est un
organisme monsieur le ministre
totalement indépendant et libre et bien
l'Autorité de la concurrence recommande
de mettre les gares bien sûr dans SNCF
réseau parce que ça fait partie de
effectivement l'infrastructure
nécessaire essentielle et un monopole
naturel
si monsieur le sénateur a vide la
commission du développement durable
monsieur le rapporteur
madame la Présidente
ces deux amendements
visent à confier à SNCF réseau la
gestion des gardes voyageurs
alors la question
a été posée par un certain nombre
d'entre vous elle a été posée aussi à ma
connaissance lors des débats à
l'Assemblée nationale et à l'Assemblée
nationale il a été prévu de mémoire
c'était à la ligne A9 de l'article 10
qu'en rapport serait présenté dans un
délai de deux ans c'est donc une clause
de revoyure qui a été acté par
l'Assemblée nationale
en effet il ne semble pas opportun de
bouleverser l'architecture actuelle du
système en transférant dès à présent la
gestion des gains SNCF réseau qui n'est
d'ailleurs pas armé pour l'instant pour
exercer cette nouvelle mission
et en effet la gestion des gains est une
mission très spécifique qui inclut la
définition des modalités d'accueil des
usagers et la valorisation d'espace
commerciaux soit des missions très
différentes de celles exercé jusqu'à
présent par Réseau ferré de France en
outre
et me tournant en particulier vers le
vinaigre qui est un défenseur de
l'ouverture à la concurrence même
anticiper
et bien je lui dirai quand l'état actuel
et bien le maintien de la gestion des
gardes ces mobilité n'apparaît pas du
tout choquant au regard du droit de la
concurrence puisque vous savez que ce
n'est pas avant probablement
2022 peut-être 2023 que l'ouverture à la
concurrence sera totale et d'ailleurs je
fais remarquer
aux deux auteurs des amendements que les
députés ont prévu des garanties en
instaurant un avis conforme
de la RAF sur les redevances sur la
tigre aux prestations fournit en gare on
n'a pas que rétablit la vie conforme de
la RAF à l'Assemblée nationale en ce qui
concerne la tarification les députés ont
aussi ajouté un avis conforme sur les
redevances relatives aux prestations
fournies dans les gars et donc je crois
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale un équilibre
a été atteint la commission a donc émis
un avis favorable bien sûr à ces deux
amendements
on avait des travaux
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
même avis défavorable
du gouvernement non sans
repréciser l'importance de ce débat
c'est un débat qui
connaîtra des prolongements d'abord
parce que monsieur le rapporteur l'a
bien expliqué je souhaite à mon tour
précisé que
il faut pas considérer que la gestion
des gares est un métier unique
et en tout cas pas en l'état un métier
de gestion d'infrastructure sinon
effectivement c'est apocanella il y
aurait une certaine logique de
considérer mais pas revenir sur les
distinctions entre les quais
et les différences aménagements
ferroviaires sur les quais selon qu'il
s'agisse des bancs ou des quais vous
n'êtes pas face au même propriétaire
même gestionnaires mais les métiers et
notamment ceux de gare et connexions ne
sont pas des métiers simplement de
gestion d'infrastructure ce sont des
métiers d'accueil ce sont des dizaines
de milliers de personnes qui aujourd'hui
ont la charge de du conseil de
l'information de l'accueil aussi des des
usagers ce qui veut dire précisément que
vous avez plusieurs missions de mission
patrimoniales mais aussi des missions
d'accueil d'information commerciale qui
se trouve être dans gare et connexions
et il était souhaitable que nous
puissions avoir une indépendance
décisionnelle de garde maintenu de gare
et connexions pour autant
l'évolution de cette structure
doit s'inscrire dans le cadre de
modernisation
qui sera le prolongement de ce projet de
loi voté par vous parce que une fois la
structure mise en place il conviendra de
pouvoir tirer pleine conséquences de
l'optimisation de l'organisation alors
est-ce qu'il s'agira de rattacher de les
couper
gare et connexion une partie
patrimoniale vers SNCF réseau une partie
vers d'autres
est-ce qu'il s'agit de maintenir une
structure qui serait bien reconnexion
avec une clarification d'émission vous
voyez que cette beaucoup par ailleurs
vous avez aussi la situation des gares
qui sont au départ purement régional
et pas simplement national
en région parisienne vous avez une
problématique qui est une problématique
supplémentaire avec le Steve notamment
donc vous voyez que aujourd'hui
l'amendement qui est présenté
certainement inspiré d'une réflexion
Visante à améliorer encore le texte je
vous en remercie Monsieur
mais je pense que la position qui est
exprimée par Monsieur kapokanella ce qui
est une forme d'appel à la réflexion
autour de cette
problématique trouve réponse dans
l'amélioration du texte suite au passage
à l'Assemblée nationale et le
gouvernement n'est pas fermé sur cette
question au contraire nous devons donner
des perspectives de la clarification
mais ne pas le faire dans un cadre
précipité de réforme il y a déjà
suffisamment à faire le cadre social
harmoniser l'ensemble de la
structuration pour que nous puissions
nous saisir rapport qui sera remis dans
les deux ans c'est en effet à l'article
10 de la loi telle que votée par
l'Assemblée nationale donc à vie
défavorable merci monsieur le ministre
je mets monsieur n'a pour une
explication de vote
les arguments du rapporteur et de
monsieur le ministre
je vais pas les balayer mais bon quand
même quand même quand vous me dites que
on va attendre monsieur le rapporteur
l'Assemblée nationale ayant décidé d'une
clause de revoyure nous devons suivre et
nous avons le droit également de
réfléchir nous avons le droit de penser
indépendamment et une clause de revoyure
monsieur le ministre vous avez dit
quelque chose qui m'a plu c'est que le
gouvernement n'est pas fermé ça prouve
donc qu'il y a effectivement un vrai
problème un vrai problème là derrière
donc je l'élimine pas d'un revers de
main je dis simplement que lorsque vous
me dites une clause de revoyure lorsque
vous me dites pas de précipitation moi
je vous renvoie à vos propres discours
dans lequel vous dites que ça fait au
moins depuis 18 mois voire plus que vous
travaillez sur cette réforme et donc
c'est pas un problème de précipitation
vous êtes en train de chambouler l'ordre
des choses actuelles et là et là
brutalement on s'arrête et on touche pas
on renvoie deux ans alors que ça fait 18
mois voire plus qu'on travaille sur ce
dossier quant à dire qu'on n'est pas
armé quand on va avoir 50000 personnes
dans lequel on va faire beaucoup de
choses je pense qu'il y a que chez nous
où on peut utiliser cet argument donc
l'argument le dernier argument que vous
utilisez c'est de dire l'ouverture à
l'autre concurrence aura lieu plus tard
c'est pas une raison suffisante pour ne
pas là encore anticiper se mettre en
ordre de bataille et faire en sorte que
n'ai justement un dispositif
adapté si monsieur le sénateur monsieur
capo Cannella
oui rapidement d'abord merci Monsieur
ministre rapporteur des explications
qu'ils ont bien voulu nous donner des
éléments d'analyse qu'on comprend bien
que c'est un sujet important et que sans
doute la réflexion n'est pas encore
totalement abouti pour autant quelques
remarques c'est l'argument du rapport en
disant le rapport va régler tout ça et
que on va remettre à plus tard mais
qu'on voit quand même regarder le sujet
je crois que d'abord s'il y a un rapport
c'est que tout le monde convient qui a
un problème et après m'a étudié dans un
cas et puis pour nous il y a un problème
à traiter à traiter plus rapidement que
sous forme de rapport le rapport à la
question c'est est-ce que c'est un
enterrement de première classe ou est-ce
que c'est un rapport destiné à traiter
le sujet
sur la vie conforme de la RAF
effectivement j'ai entendu l'argument
mais c'est ta vie confort de la RAF pour
l'égard concerne uniquement les
redevances quant aux prestations hangar
la question que nous posons c'est pas
forcément les redevances les si on nous
posons c'est la prestation en gare c'est
à dire qu'est-ce qui est offert aux
opérateurs en clair est-ce qu'un
opérateur nouveau va s'adresser demain à
SNCF mobilité et que à ce moment-là
qu'elle sera sa garantie ou plutôt
lorsque un opérateur nouveau va demain
s'adressait à SNCF mobilité qu'elle sera
sa garantie il sera au fond à droite
dans la cour arrière où il sera devant
sur les quais et bien visible c'est ça
la question c'est ça c'est là qui est le
débat et c'est là qui est le problème
c'est à dire est-ce qu'il y aura un égal
accès à la prestation voilà c'est pas la
question du niveau de la redevance donc
je pense pas que la RAF est capacité
aujourd'hui à regarder si la réponse qui
sera faite aux opérateurs sera équitable
la réponse sera faite par SN CF mobilité
qui aura forcément pris les meilleurs
endroits et c'est normal ils les ont
déjà il faudra demain faire de la place
pour les autres c'est ce problème là que
que nous visons
si je poussais le raisonnement j'ai
entendu monsieur ministre et je
comprends l'argument j'avais un moyen un
petit peu évoqué parce que je sais que
Guillaume pepite l'a abordé plusieurs
fois je craque à propos aussi en disant
c'est un métier finalement qui est
différent du réseau parce qu'il s'agisse
d'un métier où il faut être en contact
avec le public accueillir des masses
pour très bien mais si je poussais ce
raisonnement là ça voudrait dire que
dans les aéroports franciliens et bien
après tout ça devrait être à Air France
de gérer l'Infra puisque Air France
accueille les voyageurs gère le transit
des bagages gère les correspondances etc
bon donc on pourrait pousser
raisonnement et dire toutes les
infrasions toutes les toutes les gardes
tous les aéroports tous les
infrastructures aéroportuaires ou de
gare sont gérés par celui qui fait la
mobilité bon il me semble que ce
raisonnement à tout de même une limite
alors bon j'ai entendu monsieur le
ministre qui nous a dit que il n'était
pas fermé non plus qu'il fallait
progresser dans dans la réflexion
alors je vais te faire une provocation
mais j'ai envie de dire que peut-être
une la solution c'est effectivement de
faire que si on dit que c'est un métier
à part l'égard peut-être faudra-t-il un
jour qui est un épique spécifique avec
le gars et connexion devient des
réplique spécifique des reconnaît déjà
une filiale de SNCF peut-être qu'il
faudrait faire un EPIC alors ça on dira
une épique de plus mais pour le coup il
y a peut-être une justification en tout
cas à regarder sur ce sujet là je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le Sénator je
mets au voile l'amendement numéro 86 qui
a recueilli deux avis défavorables la
commission là le gouvernement qui est
pour
l'amendement 86
qui est contre cet amendement n'est pas
adopté
amendement cette rectifié à l'idée
favorable de la commission avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre cet abonnement n'est pas
adopté nous en venons à la rendement
pardon 126 rectifié madame Escoffier
vous avez la parole
présidente monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre je crains le pire
parce que vous aviez refusé un
amendement précédent présenté à la fois
par Monsieur Negret par moi-même alors
je crois que dans la même logique il est
raisonnable et utile de retirer mon
amendement si Madame la Ministre deux
amendements discussions sur l'article 2
le 53 madame Church pour le présenter
oui madame la Présidente par cet
amendement nous proposons de supprimer
au sein de cet article la possibilité
offerte à SNCF réseau de confier la
gestion des lignes à faible trafic à
d'autres opérateurs quels seront ces
lignes à faible trafic nous craignons
pour notre part qu'il ne s'agisse pas
simplement des lignes touristiques dans
ce cadre et vous le savez nous n'avons
jamais été particulièrement favorable
aux opérateurs ferroviaires de proximité
dans le cadre du fret ferroviaire pour
les réseaux capillaires l'expérience
d'ailleurs renforce notre analyse car
ces opérateurs de proximité n'ont pas
connu les sort promis lors de la
création aujourd'hui simplement neuf
opérateurs de proximité ont été créés et
reconnaissant que c'est souvent la SNCF
elle-même qui a été à l'initiative de
cette construction nous estimons donc
que la faculté offerte par cet article
ou vos grands la porte à SNCF réseau
pour se débarrasser d'une partie du
réseau ferroviaire peut utiliser et
souvent malheureusement dégradé une
telle démarche aboutirait donc
clairement à une rétraction du réseau
ferroviaire et ferait peser des risques
sur la sécurité sur le fond à nos yeux
la question n'est pas tant de savoir qui
gère l'infrastructure mais plutôt quels
sont les financements pour ces
infrastructures nous préférons donc et
nous en reparlerons plus loin dans ce
débat élargir les missions de service
public du groupe public ferroviaire
plutôt que de le voir se départir d'une
partie de l'infrastructure sur des
opérateurs de proximité qui ne portent
aucune mission de service public et dont
les caractéristiques ne sont même pas
précisées dans la loi
par ailleurs nous estimons qu'une telle
disposition porte clairement atteinte à
l'unicité du réseau qu'elles nous sont
nous sommes très attachés en multipliant
justement ces gestionnaires
d'infrastructures c'est pourquoi nous
vous proposons la suppression de cette
alinéa si chers collègues pour
l'amendement 127 rectifiés madame
Escoffier
oui merci madame la Présidente bon
l'amendement que je présente va dans un
sens tout à fait contraire puisque non
seulement il maintient
l'alinéa en soulignant d'ailleurs que
c'est un alinéa qui et c'est très bien
comme cela vient corriger des
dispositions antérieures qui étaient
tout à fait impressible et qui voudrait
éviter que résoudre France qui semble
avoir un comportement parfois un peu
réticent par rapport aux lignes
touristiques veuille bien à l'inverse en
accepté le principe alors je voudrais
insister quand même sur la nécessité de
ces petites lignes touristiques qui sont
qui circulent sur des voies ferrées de
faibles de faibles de faibles densité je
le sais bien mais tout le monde connaît
par exemple Capdenac-Gare tout le monde
connaît Capdenac-Gare et bien cap de
Nagar nous avons un vieux petit train
qui circule touristique sur la plus
grande des gares vous savez bien de
l'Aveyron mais sans parler de
Capdenac-Gare si vous parlez de Valérie
sur Somme sur reparler de bien d'autres
petites lignes touristiques c'est vrai
que derrière tout cela il y a un enjeu
économique qui est considérable pour ces
territoires et je crois que dans notre
dans notre pays aujourd'hui nous ne
devons pas négliger les territoires qui
ne sont pas les territoires
métropolitains et ce sur lesquels
justement il y a ces petites lignes où
il nous faut faire valoir ce qu'est
notre patrimoine et tout à l'heure
monsieur le ministre vous défendiez le
patrimoine et bien le patrimoine c'est
aussi celui de l'ensemble de nos
territoires c'est l'ensemble de ces
petits trains touristiques de ces
paysages qu'il nous faut faire qu'il
nous faut valoriser et l'objectif de cet
amendement c'est simplement de faire en
sorte que l'on n'oublie pas que que
notre hum touristique font partie de ce
patrimoine merci merci Madame Escoffier
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
alors cet amendement je parle bien du 53
supprime la possibilité qu'à SNCF réseau
de déléguer une partie de ces missions à
des tiers pour des lignes à faible
trafic et les infrastructures de
services
d'abord un commentaire personnel avant
de donner la ville de la Commission
j'adhère totalement à la volonté
exprimée par les auteurs de l'amendement
de défendre l'unicité du réseau national
vous savez d'ailleurs que j'en ai
toujours été un ardent défenseur c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle j'ai
fait voter par la commission la semaine
dernière un amendement et qui affirme de
la manière la plus claire que SNCF
réseau et le propriétaire unique de
l'ensemble des lignes du réseau ferré
national
alors j'en viens maintenant plus
précisément à la ville de la Commission
la Commission a estimé que le dispositif
de délégation des missions de SNCF
réseau à des tiers et de porter limitée
d'ailleurs j'en ai eu par ailleurs
l'assurance de la part du ministère en
effet il existe déjà dans le droit
actuel pour ligne à faire le trafic
réservé aux transports de marchandises
il a d'ailleurs permis le développement
des opérateurs ferroviaires de proximité
dont le rôle n'est pas négligeable dans
le maintien du frais de ferroviaire qui
a le plus grand besoin de se développer
il s'agit simplement d'autoriser
l'exploitation de certaines lignes en
particulier par des trains touristiques
en outre je rappelle que SNCF réseau
reste bien le propriétaire de ces lignes
et qu'il continue à encadrer ce type de
délégation par convention ceci explique
que la Commission était mis un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
en ce qui concerne l'amendement 127
d'Anne-Marie Escoffier il prévoit
expressément le cas de la circulation
des trains touristiques pour la
délégation parisienne d'une partie de
ces missions sur les lignes à faible
trafic alors ce que nous avons estimé à
la commission durable c'est que le
dispositif retenir l'Assemblée nationale
à expressément prévu finalement
ce cas de figure et donc il nous semble
pas nécessaire
d'ajouter cette précision
l'alinéa11 nous paraît déjà suffisamment
explicite avis défavorable de la
commission pour cette raison
c'est le rapporteur monsieur le ministre
pour le gouvernement
madame la Présidente dans le droit fil
de ce qui explose monsieur le rapporteur
je pense que il est important de tirer
pleine conséquences de ce que peuvent
apporter les opérateurs ferroviaires de
proximité notamment pour ceux et là
c'est un désaccord que nous avons
notamment pour ce qui est de sauver un
certain nombre de réseaux qui peuvent
être des réseaux capillaires se peuvent
être aussi des réseaux touristiques et
Madame la Ministre
Capdenac-Gare et désormais très célèbre
et vous avez eu raison de souligner
combien ce haut lieu de discussions
voire même de revendications méritée
toute notre attention et Monsieur
rapporteur a précisé mais nous irons à
Capdenac-Gare
nous monsieur rapporteur a précisé
combien la notion de train touristique
était satisfaite c'est très important
parce que c'est du patrimoine voyez pour
vous rassurer madame la sénatrice il
s'agit de petites lignes
quelques kilomètres qui si elle n'était
pas exploitée par des opérateurs de
proximité ce peut-être touristique ce
peut-être de marchandises ce pourquoi il
ne faut pas limiter simple transport de
marchandises puis un certain nombre de
lignes seraient déjà fermé je pense à
Cercy-la-Tour et Corbigny 80 km en
Bourgogne je pense à
neuilly-sur-avre et à brillant sur ours
et également le train très important
entre les lômes et les poisse pour 85 km
en trois vallon et hautain entre Nevers
et
entre Clamecy et en train il y en a
beaucoup
Castelsarrasin et Beaumont de Lomagne ce
sont des petits trains qui sont des
petites lignes qui sont importantes qui
peuvent être touristiquement
valorisantes et d'ailleurs avec Madame
Fleur Pellerin nous aurons un travail
été engagé sur lesquels nous souhaitons
valoriser les trains touristiques parce
que c'est une façon de découvrir le
patrimoine français et plus par ailleurs
nous avons dans ce texte et ce sera pour
la première fois proposé et présenter
par amendement du Gouvernement de la
Haute Assemblée la volonté lorsque nous
faisons référence aux opérateurs de
proximité ferroviaire de proximité dans
le droit fil de la du plan de relance la
stratégie de relance portuaire que
j'avais présenté il y a plus d'un an de
clarifier le régime juridique des voies
ferrées et d'inciter les autorités
portuaires ou les gestionnaires
portuaires les concessionnaires
portuaires de s'adresser
aux opérateurs historiques ou un
opérateur ferroviaire de proximité pour
améliorer le lien Terre Mère et
faire en sorte que les ne logistiques
que peuvent représenter les réseaux
ferroviaires portuaires souvent
inutilisées qui sont vides non pas par
manque d'équilibre économique parce que
la question n'a pas même été posée de
s'interroger sur la valorisation de ces
espaces ferroviaires et nous avons des
réseaux des faisceaux portuels
portuaires qui aujourd'hui pourrait être
valorisé pourraient répondre à la terre
modalité et au report modal sans même
que cette question n'est préoccupée
parfois les autorités portuaires ou les
gestionnaires les concessionnaires donc
il est des situations
où la notion d'opérateur ferroviaire de
proximité peut être une réponse elle
doit pas être généralisée et je vous
rejoins il s'agit pas de démanteler de
démembrer l'ensemble du système
ferroviaire mais la portée du
pragmatisme de l'équilibre économique et
peut-être de l'impulsion politique pour
donner plus de place encore au
ferroviaire donc donc madame la ministre
le l'amendement est satisfait donc
peut-être retrait puisque satisfait et
puis avis défavorablement excusé mais
c'est que pour nous là vraiment une
différence sensible d'approche
vous avez été sollicité
je suis persuadée que tout le monde aura
compris que je voulais défendre les
grands sites Midi-Pyrénéens et à
l'intérieur des grands sites
Midi-Pyrénéens cap de Naga mais au-delà
c'est vrai je suis heureuse d'avoir
entendu ce débat qui permettra de bien
retenir que ces trains là mais pas
simplement là je l'ai entendu monsieur
Teston puisse bénéficier de ce
dispositif merci donc je retire mon
amendement si Madame la Ministre donc
cet amendement 127 rectifié
et retiré madame Giraud excusez-moi
je voulais
je vous laisse excusez-moi monsieur le
ministre je trouve que vos précisions
sont extrêmement importantes et je crois
que il faut effectivement de se donner
de la souplesse moi je pense aux petits
trains de La Mure par exemple en Isère
qui est un train touristique mais je
pense aussi qu'il faut que nous soyons
voilà il faut que nous soyons aussi très
vigilants et je pense que il est
important que SNCF réseau prennent toute
l'importance y compris des lignes
classées de cette A9 vous savez que la
desserte des Alpes est un souci pour les
élus pas seulement de Rhône-Alpes de
Provence aussi de PACA pour notre mon
collègue Joël Giraud donc je pense qu'il
faut pour aussi Didier Guillaume sur la
ligne Valence dit donc il faut bien
qu'on ait cette vision de l'ensemble du
réseau et je crois que on est prêt il
est collectivités locales sont prêtes à
travailler avec
l'ensemble des opérateurs ferroviaires
et l'État sur l'ensemble de ces
questions dans le cadre des contrats de
plans mais je voulais juste rappeler que
cette question elle était aussi très
importante pour nous et vigilant il
fallait qu'on soit très vigilant parce
qu'on est servait des territoires avec
une économie réelle importante et pas
seulement touristique aussi touristique
mais pas seulement touristique si madame
la sénatrice monsieur
sur l'amendement numéro 53 je suis très
heureux de voir l'évolution année après
année du gouvernement qui aujourd'hui
défend et j'avais un petit peu monsieur
le ministre il y a déjà quelques années
sur les OSP un souhaitant qu'il y ait la
possibilité comme j'ai pu le constater
dans d'autres pays européens la
possibilité d'avoir des opérateurs
ferroviaires de proximité vous avez et
vous abondez maintenant dans ce sens
vous défendez cette position là ça me
convient parfaitement ça fait des années
que je répète la nécessité d'ouvrir vers
ces opérateurs ferroviaire de proximité
qui au départ n'ont pas été c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire aider pareil
SNCF pour fonctionner alors qu'il
s'agissait d'entreprises locales qui
simplement développer développer un
marché donc de l'emploi sur le plan
local
merci donc de cette évolution positive
le deuxième point c'est que je voudrais
en profiter pour attirer votre attention
directement monsieur le ministre sur la
ligne internationale mais qui doit être
classée
ui C cette année9 qui va de Nice à Turin
et pour lequel nous avons quelques
petites dizaines de millions d'euros de
frais à faire pour récupérer cette ligne
parce que sinon aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
le niveau de service a baissé il y a
certains passages où on roule à 40 km à
l'heure sur une sur une ligne
internationale voilà aussi la situation
du ferroviaire en France et je termine
une fois n'est pas coutume pour rendre
hommage après le gouvernement
à la région PACA la région PACA a pris
un charge la ligne Nice digne et grâce
aux investissements des collectivités
puisque le Conseil Général également
particip e on a sauvé cette ligne donc
ne bridez pas cette liberté aux uns et
aux autres d'intervenir sachant que de
toute manière le réseau national n'est
absolument pas affecté
monsieur le sénateur pour une
explication de vote madame cherche
oui madame la Présidente je vais donc
bien sûr maintenir mon amendement car
j'estime si vous voulez que dans dans ce
cet alinéa nous ne définissons pas très
clairement les lignes à faible trafic
parce qu'on me dit c'est les petites
lignes touristiques par-ci par-là bah
d'accord mais moi qui vient de mon Luçon
j'utilise une ligne à faible trafic tu
es toujours en déshérence qui est mal
enfin qui qui ralentit très très souvent
enfin on a quand même beaucoup de
dysfonctionnements c'est une ligne à
faible trafic donc je suis interrogative
et je continue de je pense que nous
aurions pu retirer cet amendement si
monsieur le ministre vous nous aviez
proposé réservé par exemple à des fins
touristiques voyez-vous mais quand il
s'agit de transport de voyageurs ou de
fret nous ne pouvons pas l'accepter
monsieur negre vous je vous comprends
aussi dans votre logique nous avons une
constance aussi qui est toujours la même
je crois qu'on se rejoint sur la
constance au moins de très éloigné et
donc je vais maintenir cet amendement
car je suis inquiète et nous sommes
inquiets pour toutes les lignes à faible
trafic et il y en a un très grand nombre
si madame la sénatrice je mets donc aux
voix l'amendement numéro 53 qui a reçu
deux avis défavorables de la Commission
et du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
cet amendement n'est pas adopté
nous avons en discussion commune 6
amendements concernant l'article 2 je
donne la parole pour l'amendement numéro
51 à Madame church
oui madame la Présidente par cet
amendement nous souhaitons en cohérence
avec la position que nous avons soutenue
à l'article premier supprimer la
possibilité offerte par le présent
article d'une contractualisation directe
entre l'État et SNCF réseau en effet
nous estimons que le contraste
stratégique doit être conclu à l'échelle
du groupe du groupe ferroviaire intégré
et donc avec les pics de tête un
fortiori nous estimons que tel que
définie par le présent article les
objectifs assignés à ce contrat sont
purement comptables et financiers bien
loin des missions de service public doit
remplir ce nouvel établissement public
les objectifs assignés à ce contrat
révèlent également le climat président à
l'organisation de ce nouveau découpage
sur fond de libéralisation des
transports en effet les questions de
performance du réseau productivité et un
mot nouveau trajectoire financière il
est d'ailleurs frappant que la loi
stipule que la RAF
donne son avis sur la soutenabilité de
l'évolution de la tarification pour le
marché du transport ferroviaire nous
sommes pardons étonnés de cette nouvelle
préoccupation de la RAF alors même que
le niveau des péages et d'ores et déjà
depuis longtemps bien trop lourd pour
l'entreprise historique
or cela ne gênait pas les pouvoirs
publics qui permettaient une
augmentation des péages à mesure que les
contributions de l'État par la loi de
finances diminuée nous sommes
extrêmement sceptiques sur l'objectif de
couverture du coût complet dans un
horizon de 10 années ajouté ici par un
amendement de la commission des finances
en effet les fameux gains de
productivité ne permettront pas à eux
seuls de la dette largement pas pour
cela il aurait fallu aller plus loin
prévoir de nouveaux financements pour le
système ferroviaire mais malheureusement
il n'est point question dans ce projet
de loi et nous le regrettons fortement
nous demandons donc purement et
simplement la suppression de ces alinéas
qui témoignent d'une vision comptable et
gestionnaire d'une structure dont les
objectifs politiques relèvent pourtant
de l'intérêt général c'est ça qu'on
essaie de faire comprendre à cette Haute
Assemblée depuis le début de nos débats
si madame la sénatrice deux amendements
identiques d'abord le 8 monsieur
il est pas sûr que l'intérêt général
soit communément admis sur tous ces bars
on voit bien la différence qui fait que
nous avons deux visions différentes
alors sur la Linéa 16 la première phrase
après le mot développement on insère le
mot d'investissement pour être plus
complet plus précis et sur la Linéa 22
on le remplace par trois alinéas qui
nous permettent de dire que le contrat
de performance de SNCF réseau n'a de
portée que s'il comporte les éléments
requis pour assurer l'équilibre
financier de manière durable c'est pour
ça que nous rajoutons l'ensemble des
ressources commerciales ainsi que la
couverture du coût complet pour des
ressources définitives au delà après les
objectifs de productivité retenue nous
inscrivons ainsi que les actions
conduites pour les réaliser
et monsieur le sénateur l'amendement 88
qui est identique monsieur capo Cannella
oui merci madame la Présidente
effectivement il est identique donc j'ai
pas grand chose à ajouter à ce que vient
de dire fort bien Louis le contrat
de performance de SNCF réseau n'a nous
semble-t-il de porter que s'il comporte
des éléments requis pour assurer
l'équilibre financier de manière durable
c'est un moment propose donc de le
compléter par la stratégie
d'investissement et par une trajectoire
financière plus détaillée
merci monsieur le sénateur l'amendement
154 monsieur Dantec pour le présenter
oui il s'agit là aussi de rajouter un
mot et ce mot c'est pérennité avec donc
un alinéa après la Linéa 24 la pérennité
du réseau ferré national je pense qu'il
est quand même important de rappeler cet
objectif et donc notamment la liste des
lignes dont SNCF réseau doit assurer la
totalité du financement des
investissements de renouvellement je
crois que cet amendement est très clair
il propose de limiter les règles au
projet de développement du réseau et
holides nouvelles afin que les budgets
alloués au développement du réseau
relevant de choix politiques ne viennent
pas amputer le budget dédié au
financement du réseau existant qui
s'appuie essentiellement sur la
redevance d'infrastructures on a un
enjeu extrêmement fort aujourd'hui sur
l'entretien et la pérennité des lignes
existantes je crois que c'est l'endroit
dans le texte où il faut le rappeler
fortement
138 monsieur
oui en l'occurrence il s'agit de tenir
l'objectif d'équilibre financier du
gestionnaire d'infrastructures qui est
absolument nécessaire à la santé
économique du système ferroviaire la
définition du coût complet du réseau
appelle quelques clarifications pour
éviter tout éventualité de double compte
d'un même coup le présent en en demande
donc la Linéa 26
vise donc à ne pas recouvrer deux fois
les dépenses liées à la construction qui
font déjà l'objet d'un amortissement
merci monsieur le sénateur amendement
137 monsieur capocanellas
oui madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues le contrat prévu entre l'État
et SNCF réseau comporte un certain
nombre de règles et de disposition
l'amendement que je vous propose pour
objet de les compléter et surtout
d'affiner la question du coût des
charges de toute nature supporter par
SNCF réseau lié à la construction à
l'exploitation à la maintenance et à
l'aménagement de l'infrastructure cet
abonnement est inspiré de la
réglementation qui concerne le secteur
de l'énergie ainsi je vais vous citer
l'article
l450 de
2-1 du code de l'énergie qui dispose que
les tarifs d'utilisation des réseaux de
transport et distribution en
l'occurrence du gaz naturel des
installations de gaz naturel qui est
fiée y compris des installations
fournissant des services auxiliaires et
de flexibilité les conditions
commerciales d'utilisation de ces
réseaux ou installations ainsi que les
tarifs des prestations annexes réalisées
par les gestionnaires de réseaux
d'installations sont établis de manière
transparente et non discriminatoire mais
surtout
afin de couvrir l'ensemble des coûts
supportés par ces gestionnaires et la
précision est importante dans la mesure
où ces coûts correspondent à ceux d'un
gestionnaire de réseau ou d'installation
efficace donc sa figure déjà cette
notion de gestionnaire efficace dans le
code de l'énergie les si cette dernière
phrase faisait partie de phrase que nous
reprenons dans cet amendement et que
nous appliquons aux réseaux ferroviaire
en effet dès lors que les entreprises
ferroviaires ont vocation à couvrir
l'ensemble des coûts du gestionnaire
d'infrastructures il ne nous serait pas
légitime qu'elle ait à payer pour des
inefficacités dont le gestionnaire
serait seul responsable donc entre
guillemets je propose d'utiliser la
jurisprudence du secteur de l'énergie
pour l'appliquer maintenant au sujet
qu'elle neutre c'est-à-dire au secteur
du ferroviaire et d'introduire cette
notion de coût correspondant à ceux d'un
gestionnaire de réseau ou d'installation
efficace voilà merci merci Monsieur le
Sénator sur ces 6 amendements la vie de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente
l'amendement 51 du groupe CRC vise à
supprimer une partie
des dispositions du contrat du contrat
conclut entre SNCF réseau et l'État
relatives à sa trajectoire financière et
aux mesures prises par SNCF réseau si
une partie manque à ses obligations il
supprime aussi la vie de la RAF sur le
contrat
la commission du développement durable a
considéré que le contrat très SNCF
réseau et l'État avec la définition
conjointe d'une trajectoire financière à
respecter est un outil pertinent qu'il
convient de conserver elle a donc émis
un avis défavorable
l'amendement numéro 8 de vinaigre
vise à compléter le contenu du contrat
en insérant notamment le détail de
l'ensemble des ressources de la SNCF
réseau ainsi que le détail des mesures
envisagées pour atteindre les objectifs
de productivité fixés par le contrat
très franchement il paraît difficile de
déterminer le niveau des ressources de
SNCF réseau sur une période de trois ans
et encore plus sur une période de 10 ans
la même question se pose d'ailleurs
s'agissant des ressources commerciales
dans ce cadre entrer dans un tel niveau
de détails ne semble guère pertinent en
ce qui concerne les objectifs de
productivité le contrat doit aller fixer
certes mais il revient ensuite à l'épics
de s'organiser pour les atteindre avis
défavorables de la commission
l'amendement 88 de Vincent capots canela
City donc même ma vie défavorable de la
commission
l'amendement numéro 154 de Ronan Dantec
et du groupe
écologiste c'est un amendement qui
prévoit que le contrat conclu entre
l'État SNCF réseau
viennent fixer la liste des lignes doit
SNCF réseau doit assurer la totalité du
financement des investissements de
renouvellement
la rédaction adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale pour l'application de la règle
de la maîtrise de l'endettement
distingue déjà d'une part les
investissements de renouvellement du
réseau existant qui doivent être assurés
par les ressources de la SNCF réseau les
péages et les subventions et d'autre
part les investissements de
développement du réseau auquel
s'applique le plus précisément
la règle d'or entre guillemets des
maîtrise de l'endettement affirmé comme
le fait cette amendement que la SNCF
doit assurer la totalité du financement
des investissements de renouvellement
sans recours à des subventions publiques
pour y entraîner une forte augmentation
des péages d'infrastructures avec à
terme des répercussions sur le prix du
transport ferroviaire sa compétitivité
par rapport aux autres modes de
transport et par conséquent aussi
l'ampleur du trafic avis défavorable de
la commission
l'amendement numéro 138 de Louis
propose une nouvelle définition du coût
de complet qui ne prend pas en compte
les charges liées à la construction du
réseau
la définition du coût complet prévue
dans le sexe ne revient pas à compter
deux fois les dépenses liées à la
construction comme semble le
sous-entendre l'amendement il est
important que les charges liées à la
construction du réseau soit inclus dans
le coût complet sinon
monsieur l'auteur de l'amendement le
coup ne serait pas complet serait
incomplet avis défavorable
l'abonnement 137 de Vincent apocanella
c'est du groupe
udi UC
vise à préciser que les seuls chargent
correspondantes à celles d'un
gestionnaire d'infrastructures efficace
sont inclus dans le calcul du coût
complet du réseau
adopter un tel amendement me paraît
dangereux parce que cela reviendrait à
remettre en cause les efforts réalisés
par le gestionnaire d'infrastructures
pour réduire l'augmentation des coûts
cela paraît difficilement acceptable et
d'ailleurs si on n'a pas été accepté par
la commission qui a émis un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur a vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre sur
ces 6 amendements
devant la précision de l'explication de
monsieur le rapporteur nous émettons les
mêmes avis
si Monsieur le Ministre donc je vais
mettre au roi ces différents amendements
commençant par l'amendement numéro 51
qui a recueilli deux avis défavorables
de la Commission et du gouvernement qui
est pour
qui est contre cet amendement n'est pas
adopté
l'amendement numéro 8 même avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement
qui est pour pardon
qui est contre cet amendement n'est pas
adopté même votre pour l'amendement
numéro
oui même votre pour l'amendement numéro
88 amendement numéro 154 de Monsieur
dentelle a vidé favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre cet amendement n'est pas
adopté amendement numéro 138 deux avis
défavorables de la Commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre cet amendement n'est pas
adopté
amendement numéro 137 de Monsieur capo
canelas a vidé favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre cet amendement n'est
pas adopté nous en avons à la discussion
commune de deux amendements l'amendement
numéro 52 c'est Madame Cohen qui le
présente vous avez la parole chers
collègues oui madame la Présidente je
vous remercie par cet amendement
continuité avec nos prises de position
précédente nous estimons qu'il convienne
supprimer au sein de cet article les
dispositions relatives à la fameuse
règle d'or ou règles prudentielles
imposées au financement des
infrastructures cet article prévoit un
cycle financement futur des
infrastructures sera soumis à des savons
règles de calcul à des ratios permettant
de limiter l'engagement financier de
SNCF réseau nous ne partageons pas cette
démarche en effet nous considérons
regard des besoins de financement tant
des infrastructures actuelles par la
régénération que de nouvelles
infrastructures qu'il convient non de
limiter ou de réduire les moyens mais
bien de trouver d'autres modalités de
financement de nouvelles ressources pour
le système ferroviaire l'absence de
cette problématique au sein de ce projet
de loi constitue d'ailleurs sa
principale lacune comme la souligné à
plusieurs reprises ma collègue Mireille
Church de fait cet article découle du
refus de l'état de reprendre la dette
ferroviaire à son compte il impose donc
à SNCF réseau une trajectoire financière
censée éponger cette dette cela ne
semble ni réalisable ni souhaitable en
effet une telle règle d'or aura
évidemment des incidences pour les
usagers en termes de qualité de service
puisque clairement les engagements
financiers seront moindres pourtant il
est indispensable de procéder à la
régénération et de créer des lignes
nouvelles qui ne sont d'ailleurs pas
forcément des lignes à grande vitesse
faut-il le souligner mais comme
d'ailleurs le propose la commission
possibilité 21 à défaut de rénovation et
selon les projections de l'École
polytechnique de Lausanne c'est
l'essentiel du réseau qui deviendra
impraticable et dangereux ce qui à terme
d'ailleurs conduira inévitablement à la
contraction de réseau sur les axes les
moins dégradés les choix opérés dans le
cadre de ce projet de loi représente
ainsi un carcan pour les investissements
ils obéiront demain directement les
capacités de financement par SNCF réseau
alors comme le démon de les analyses à
propos de l'accident de Brétigny le
réseau est d'ores et déjà dans un état
lamentable et cet engagement financier
est nécessaire et urgent appliquer les
principes d'austérité au financement des
infrastructures et donc non seulement un
non sens par rapport aux besoins mais
également potentiellement source de
danger et d'accidents à venir nous
demandons donc la suppression de la
fameuse règle d'or règle d'or d'autant
plus absieuse qu'à défaut de financement
par SNCF réseau ce serait à l'état et au
collectivités de supplés elle-même
largement asphyxiés par la baisse des
dotations l'ensemble de ces vraiment
créer une spirale du déclin de
l'investissement et de l'action publique
totalement négative pour le service
public de transport de voyageurs et de
marchandises je vous remercie merci
madame la sénatrice l'amendement 113
pour le présenter monsieur capo canelas
merci
collègues les alinéa 30 à 32 de cet
article prévoit qu'un décret fixe les
règles de financement des
investissements de SNCF réseau en vue de
maîtriser sa dette il propose ainsi que
les investissements de développement
soient évolués suivant des ratios fixés
par décret cet amendement a pour
objectif de renforcer le rôle du
Parlement en prévoyant que les ratios
notamment le ratio dette sur marge
opérationnelle permettant d'évaluer les
projets d'investissement de
développement du réseau ferré national
soit définie chaque année en loi de
finances et non par décret ça permet au
Parlement d'avoir voix au chapitre sur
un sujet qui est quand même majeur qui
est celui du financement des projets
d'investissement dans les
infrastructures de réseau et je ne doute
pas que le CNA soit sensible à la
capacité qui lui sera ainsi donné
d'avoir vos chapitres sur ce sujet
majeur faut de quoi nous constaterions
ici les conséquences du décret et que il
y a pas de marge de manœuvre le plus
souvent le dépassement de ce ratio
empêche toute participation de SNCF
réseau au financement ses
investissements alors il s'agit
simplement qui est un débat j'ai pas
forcément de faire que tous les ratios
soient explosés mais au contraire que
l'on puisse avoir les termes du débat
ici et pas subapticement et permettre
ainsi au parlementaire de s'exprimer et
donc d'être responsable donc il vous est
proposé que ça soit au stade de la loi
de finances que ce ratio soit fixé
chaque année sera voté par le Parlement
et il y aura donc un débat sur ce ratio
chaque année
si monsieur le sénateur la vie de la
Commission sur ces deux amendements
monsieur le rapporteur merci madame la
Présidente avant de donner la ville la
commission sur l'amendement 52 je
voudrais m'adresser amicalement à
Laurence coin en lui disant que on ne
peut pas accepter l'affirmation
selon laquelle le réseau ferroviaire
français serait dans un état lamentable
il y a eu dans le passé
et pendant plusieurs décennies un
sous-investissement pour la régénération
de ce réseau et après les deux études
qui ont été menées par l'École
polytechnique de Lausanne des efforts
ont été engagés d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre a rappelé hier qu'il y a un
grand plan de modération du réseau qui
prévoit 15 milliards d'euros
d'investissement sur 6 ans
et donc aujourd'hui on sait qu'avec cet
effort on va progressivement pouvoir
remettre à niveau sur une période de 10
ans l'intégralité ou une très grande
partie du réseau classique donc je pense
qu'il est important de le rappeler il y
a eu certes la catastrophe de Brétigny
il y a effectivement peut-être un
certain nombre d'améliorations à
apporter sur ce réseau mais dire que
tout le réseau serait dans un état
lamentable je ne peux pas l'accepter en
tant que rapporteur de ce projet de loi
ceci étant janvier maintenant à
l'amendement numéro
52 par lequel le groupe CRC propose de
supprimer finalement cela revient ça en
supprimant les alinés à 21 29 à 36 la
règle de maîtrise de l'endettement du
réseau
or cette règle ne maîtrise de
l'endettement du réseau est un des
outils proposés par le projet de loi
pour lutter efficacement contre la
dérive de l'endettement du réseau donc
nous ne pouvons pas laisser de côté
cette question essentielle d'endettement
du réseau c'est la raison pour laquelle
la commission a émis un avis défavorable
l'amendement 113 du groupe donc
udi UC présenté par Vincent kapocanella
propose que les ratios établis dans le
cadre de la règle de maîtrise de
l'endettement ne soit pas définie par
décret mais chaque année la loi de
finance alors la commission
considérer que le calcul des ratio est
un sujet extrêmement technique en outre
il est apparu aussi que ces ratio
devaient être fixés dans une perspective
pluriannuelle et non annuellement et
donc leur présentation loi de finance ne
semble pas la plus adéquate c'est la
raison pour laquelle la commission a
émis un avis défavorable si monsieur le
rapporteur pour le gouvernement la vie
du ministre
en quelques mots madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs quelques mots puisque c'est un
des axes importants de ce projet de loi
de prendre enfin pleine conscience de ce
que nous avons comme difficulté de
financement des infrastructures de
transport ferroviaire et surtout de ne
pas tomber dans les mêmes travers de ce
que nous avons connu les années
précédentes se rapportera rappeler les
mesures d'urgence qui ont été prises à
la fois sur le grand plan de
modernisation des infrastructures et le
réseau de milliard 5 et
immédiatement après Brétigny les sommes
qui ont été consacrées 410 millions pour
les vérifications et travaux d'urgence
évidemment mais pourquoi en sommes-nous
arrivés à cette situation tout
simplement parce que l'on a considéré
que sous prétexte qu'il s'agissait
d'opérateurs publics on pouvait
s'affranchir de toute rigueur financière
que l'on pouvait laisser aux générations
futures
à ceux qui auraient la charge de
succéder
aux personnes prenant des décisions les
modalités de financement de ce qui
n'était pas finançable pendant l'exemple
des quatre lignes LGV les quatre lignes
LGV concomitamment ont amené à ce que
n'ayons pas la possibilité de supporter
sauf à faire porter le financement sur
de l'emprunt et donc sur de la dette
nous ne pouvions pas avoir l'équilibre
économique de ces infras sur lancée et
cela se traduit au détriment du réseau
détriment de l'entretien de la
modernisation de l'existant nous
réorientons cela je l'ai indiqué avec le
souci de ligoter de ligoter le
dispositif par cette fameuse règle d'or
le principe c'est que la mission SNCF
réseau soit axé sur le financement de
l'existant la modernisation le
renouvellement et que dès lors qu'il y
aurait des investissements
d'infrastructures nouvelles
celle-ci devait être conditionnée
ceci ces investissements doivent être
conditionnés à la capacité pour SNCF
réseau de pouvoir financer si tel n'est
pas le cas il s'agit pas de refuser la
phrase structure et l'investissement
mais c'est tout simplement de d'inviter
celles et ceux des
autorités décisionnaires
de d'assumer le choix que l'on fait
porter sur SNCF réseau c'est-à-dire de
le financer en lieu et place SNCF réseau
qui ne pourra pas le financer donc nous
sommes là dans cette campagne ça j'ai
pas d'interdire l'investissement mais si
c'est à ce point important d'intérêt
national les toits l'État doit prendre
la part de la dette nouvelle qu'il
souhaitait mettre à la charge du réseau
si ce sont des investissements
intéressants les collectivités locales
celle-ci prendront à défaut de capacité
pour RFM de supporter la dette nouvelle
et bien devant en prendre pleine
responsabilités voilà donc je maintiens
à cette explication cette règle d'or est
très importante parce que nous faisons
œuvre de responsabilité par rapport aux
générations qui viennent notre objectif
est la stabilisation à 10 ans de la
dette c'était un processus long mais ce
sont des pareils garde-fous qui vous
permettront de d'assurer une remise en
perspective d'une trajectoire financière
qui n'a été faut le dire que victime
d'un conséquence des choix politiques
alors lorsqu'il y a des choix politiques
ils doivent être assumés ils doivent
être financés et ils ne peuvent pas se
traduire par une course en avant qui
touche à la sécurité qui touche à la
qualité des infrastructures et qui
touche au cœur de métier de gestionnaire
de réseau
merci Monsieur le Ministre j'ai une
demande d'explication de vote de Madame
Laurence Cohen
oui merci madame la Présidente je pense
que c'est indispensable de
d'entendre les propos qui qui ont été
tenus parce que quand je décris l'état
du réseau d'abord c'est pas tout le
réseau il y a un certain nombre de
lignes effectivement et on peut pas dire
qu'il soit dans un état florissant et
les raisons pour lesquelles il est dans
cet état-là c'est effectivement un
désengagement extrêmement important de
l'État une certaine époque je vais le
dire comme ça donc c'est vrai que là il
y a un effort manifeste qui est fait
mais il faut voir la hauteur de la
nécessité
de l'effort qui devrait être porté et
donc qui nécessiterait des financements
extrêmement importants je veux dire que
quiconque s'occupe des transports et de
la tous les élus qui sont présents
notamment dans cette émission dans cette
hémicycle savent très bien que il est
nécessaire d'investir
des moyens extrêmement importants quand
il s'agit de rénover d'améliorer le
service le service public et le souci
qu'on a au travers de cet amendement
c'est de souligner une nouvelle fois
parce que c'est important qu'on ne peut
pas en rester effectivement un statut
court en matière de financement et qu'il
est indispensable de trouver de nouveaux
financements si on veut répondre à
l'amélioration
du service rendu à la population et je
crois que c'est ce qui ce qui nous guide
ici c'est la portée de cet amendement il
s'agit pas de s'y méprendre et je pense
que ne pas réfléchir à ces pistes ne pas
essayer d'entendre ce que nous portons
et bien est une vue pour moi à court
terme et donc c'est pourquoi nous nous
récidivons tout au cours de ce débat
pour attirer l'attention et faire en
sorte que de nouveaux financement soit
débloqué
si madame la sénatrice monsieur
pourrait l'explication de vote
j'aurais aimé chers collègues que de là
de dire il faut de nouvelles ressources
il y a qu'à faucon vous aurez pu nous
dire également vous auriez pu nous dire
également quels sont les nouvelles
ressources que vous visez moi ce que je
vais dire c'est que l'état du réseau
dégradé ne date pas d'aujourd'hui déjà
dès 2005 dès 2005
tout à fait
honnête monsieur le ministre il faut
dire la vérité bon donc l'état du réseau
en 2005 l'École polytechnique de
Lausanne nous alerte sur l'état du
réseau et nous dit qu'on est en voie
justement de délabrement en 2012 en 2012
chers collègues l'École polytechnique de
Lausanne rappelle que nous avons fait
des progrès mais ils sont bien
insuffisants et même la cour de Kant 6
mai donc nous avons un réseau qui a
vieilli un réseau sur lequel nous avons
mis l'essentiel de l'argent et tout le
monde tout le monde tout ban confondu on
a effectivement soutenu à fond le TGV on
a oublié en partie le réseau classique
et j'ai même et j'ai même à ce niveau-là
une observation un peu taquine voire
critique à l'égard de la CGT qui fait
grève à tout bout de champ et qui aurait
dû puisque ce sont les cheminots qui
sont sur le terrain qui auraient dû dire
depuis longtemps au pouvoir politique je
fais grève parce que le réseau classique
s'effondre sous mes yeux et bien j'ai
pas vu la grève de la CGT pour pour
alerter les pouvoirs publics là-dessus
donc sur l'état du réseau ce que nous
constatons sur l'état du réseau madame
ce que nous constatons c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a un effort
conséquent qui est fait il y a mille
chantiers on n'a jamais autant investi
et donc à partir de là à partir de là
vous avez des conséquences heureuses on
est en train de récupérer le réseau tous
ensemble mais le réseau continue à
vieillir jusqu'en 2018 donc il va encore
le ministre je vous ai pas interrompu
tout de suite il faut tirer la
couverture à soi il faut espérer vivre
encore un peu bon écoutez c'est le
peuple qui décidera à ces niveaux ni moi
on verra bien cette quelle sera l'avenir
de ce Couvernement bien donc ceci étant
on constate que des efforts conséquences
ont fait aujourd'hui la fit c'est
engagée vous savez que on manque
d'argent au niveau de l'Agence de
financement suite effectivement la
suspension malheureuse monsieur le
ministre de l'écotaxe où j'ai constaté
que vous aviez dû reculer face à une
levée de fourche bretonne alors je me
demande quand mais bon ces fourches
bretonnes nous ont amenés à une
situation aujourd'hui ou il nous manque
dans les caisses au minimum 800 millions
d'euros qu'on a perdu qu'on a perdu
parce que s'ils sont pas rentrés dans
les caisses de l'État au sens large et
donc dans nos infrastructures c'est 800
millions sont ailleurs et sur deux ans
j'ai compté ça fait un milliard 6 quand
même alors à force de effectivement de
prendre des positions de suspension de
taxes qui a été votée à l'unanimité on
en arrive là le deuxième point vous les
ressources nouvelles c'est quoi les
ressources nouvelles
bien les ressources nouvelles et bien
vous avez par exemple la fraude là
encore tout à l'heure je disais qui
parle des usagers et bien la fraude
c'est 400 millions d'euros 400 millions
d'euros uniquement sur deux opérateurs
uniquement sur deux opérateurs et là le
gars je pense que le ministre aussi nous
nous retrouvons tous sur la même ligne
il n'y a aucune raison qu'il y ait 400
millions de fraudes parce que les 400
millions vont manquer dans les
infrastructures et on va faire payer les
400 millions à ceux qui eux payent bon
c'est un civique possible c'est une
fraude donc c'est condamnable et je
dirais qu'il faut travailler davantage
en France sur cet aspect il y a certains
pays au monde dans lequel il y a
quasiment zéro fraude quasiment 0 prod
pourquoi acceptons-nous pourquoi notre
pays accepte ces centaines de millions
de fraudes ça c'est une question la
première la deuxième
ou là excusez-moi la deuxième c'est la
clientèle pour lequel on paye 30%
aujourd'hui et c'est vraisemblablement
en des taux les plus bas d'Europe et
troisièmement la productivité qu'il
faudrait augmenter et Monsieur
capocanellas
merci madame la Présidente je souhaitais
revenir sur
l'application en explication de votre
sur le 113 dont je rappelle qu'il vise à
permettre au Parlement de débattre tous
les ans sur le fameux ratio qui sera
opposé à SNCF réseau dans le financement
des investissements ce point est un
point important parce que
si le ratio est fixé par décret le
Parlement constatera que il y a rien à
débattre qu'il n'y a pas lieu de
débattre il n'y aura aucune discussion
sur l'opportunité de financer ou pas des
projets parce que le décret aura fixé la
toise et donc Bercy aura estimé à notre
place que le débat est escamoté et donc
je comprends et j'admire notre
rapporteur michel Teston qui avait
talent et un brin discipline quand même
et est amené grand talent monsieur le
Président effectivement
et un petit peu de discipline quand même
parce que effectivement il faut soutenir
l'exécutif et je le comprends c'est
toujours difficile d'être rapporteur il
faut prendre en compte les différentes
exigences et il le fait effectivement
fort bien mais que la Commission nous
invite à priver le Parlement du vrai
débat sur le financement là j'ai quand
même plus qu'un doute une interrogation
et il me semble que il faut qu'on s'y
arrête un petit peu alors venir nous
dire que
ce problème de ratio est très technique
et que donc comme ces techniques et que
c'est financier on va priver le
Parlement de la discussion sur le ratio
là ça me sidère un peu malgré toutes
l'estime que j'ai promis chez eston et
tout et son talent là-dessus je pense
que son talent c'est plus un peu parce
que c'est quand même compliqué parce que
dire que on peut pas le mettre en loi de
finance parce que c'est technique et
c'est financier en tout cas il a dit ces
techniques du moins la loi de finances
ne comporte que des éléments techniques
donc celui-ci en est un et pas sur un
petit sujet et donc le Parlement se
prononce sur le budget de l'État il peut
aussi se prononcer
sur cette question là donc je pense que
ce point mérite d'être regardé est-ce
que nous souhaitons en tant que
parlementaire être décisif ou pas c'est
toute la question qui est posée au
travers cet abandon centrale moi je vous
invite à le voter parce que c'est
redonner au Parlement toute sa puissance
sur la politique ferroviaire je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le sénateur madame Didier
pour une explication de vote
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues juste pour
rappeler à notre collègue qui est un peu
jeune dans cette assemblée que nous
entendons en réalité parler de l'état du
réseau depuis bien avant 2005 et que
c'est parce que justement un certain
nombre de personnes ont alerté sur
l'état du réseau et notamment notamment
je vous invite à relire les travaux de
votre collègue Gerbault qui était membre
de la commission des affaires
économiques et dont ce cercle certains
se souviennent ici et qui très
régulièrement nous rappelait que ce
réseau était en difficulté les cheminots
d'ailleurs le disaient également et on
savait pertinemment quand on connaissait
un peu le sujet que les trains au fur et
à mesure que le réseau s'est dégradé on
les a ralentis et que progressivement on
est on en est arrivé à faire passer à
certains sur certains tronçons les
trains des vitesses vraiment très très
faibles donc revenons longtemps en
arrière c'est une responsabilité qui est
celle de tous les gouvernements depuis
très longtemps donc ça il faut lacter de
même que d'ailleurs le financement de la
fuite ça ne date pas d'aujourd'hui que
la vie n'a pas les moyens dès le départ
on ne lui a pas donné les moyens qui a
créé la fille donc voilà je pense qu'il
faut qu'on revienne à des propos
raisonnables dans cette assemblée et que
on évite de tout le temps renvoyer les
responsabilités parce que là franchement
pas grand monde et et éclair sur ce
sujet nous quittons l'hémicycle du Sénat
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance
prochain rendez-vous avec les travaux
parlementaires cet après-midi à partir
de 15 heures les sénateurs poursuivent
l'examen de la réforme ferroviaire
c'est un territoire qui fait souvent la
une de l'actualité pour ses
affrontements entre bande rivales